welcome to the heavy spoilers show as
always I'm your captain definition we're
at the final frontier of Picard with
season one now officially coming to an
end there's a lot to unpack from the
latest entry and throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down everything
that happens in the new episode and what
the ending means a couple of theories
came true
a couple didn't and overall there's a
lot to discuss in this extremely
emotional episode we will be engaging
with heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to catch the show
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and if you enjoyed the coverage then
please drop a thumbs up without the way
thank you for clicking the video now
let's get into our breakdown of Picard
episode 10 the episode opens with narak
fleeing to the ball cube after he
escaped or was rather let free by Sutra
last week he's pretty much become a wild
card that could bring her revolution
crashing down as he sneaks in we see
Ellen all and seven of nine discussing
their kinship and how neither really
have a home this sort of plays into the
ending of the episode which we'll
discuss later in the video but there is
this aesthetic laced throughout the
entry l know is of course from Romulus
which was destroyed during the supernova
and it's nice to see them at least
paying lip service to their similarities
Nerissa has been hiding on the cube but
I'm sure we saw her get beamed out of
there when the Borg ambushed her
there was definitely a glow and then we
watched the ships leave the area but my
mistake if I took that the wrong way I
think that this return was pretty poorly
handled as she did get swamped and then
all of a sudden she's just been hiding
out a lot of the characters have just
shown it when they needed to and I don't
know it just feels like a bit of lazy
writing the two end up splitting up and
as predicted narrow ends of changing
sides during the entry he's had a strong
connection with shoji throughout the
season and this does make a lot of sense
for a number of reasons
anyway Picard is on house arrest and
Xochi visits him here he tries to
dissuade her from building the beacon to
some of the higher level since that can
wipe out all of life in the universe I
love the line where Picard states that
thinking that they have no choice is a
lack of imagination and over
also Patrick Stewart does a great job of
arguing his point throughout the entry
you can see him slowly start to win so
around and he has some big moments in
this finale also hats off to Esau
Brianna's who's played so gee dodge and
Sutra throughout the season each
character has felt different to the
other and she's probably had the
toughest job out of all of the cast and
has handled it really well
Rafi and arias reactivate the ship and
Eric reaches out to them in order to
save the universe this has been his gold
throughout the season and I don't really
think it mattered to him too much which
side he was on and thus him going or
Benedict Arnold is actually believable
he tells the story of gamma Dom an
ancient myth similar to Ragnarok which
prophesizes two demon sisters that come
at the end of time and unleash a great
amount of monsters through blowing a
horn it is of course very similar to
this episode and rather than being a
prophecy narak actually believes that
it's history which will repeat itself
agnes talks with soon about activating
the synthetic body that will allow him
to do a mind transfer now it's rather a
shout out other YouTube channels but
definitely check out our partner one
bomb alarm which dropped a fan Theory
last week that said soon was law it
doesn't turn out to be true
but it actually makes this episode seem
a lot better and he argues some great
points it's definitely a challenge you
should be checking out in general and
his theories got me thinking a lot about
Sutra and what she represents similar to
law Sutra and Janna were created first
before Sochi and dodged laws made to
perfect in some ways and this had
massive effects on his personality and
thus he became a narcissist that
believed himself superior to humans this
motif is seen in Sutra who to was
created to be perfect she's pretty much
seen as the leader of the synths and has
likely ruled over the colony even
placing herself above soon in many ways
this episode does indicate that she has
supplanted her creator and thus she is
the perfect person or rather Android to
fit the role of the destroyer she hasn't
seen first hand organic life and has
only really heard stories about their
prejudices juxtaposing this Shoji
actually has and she realizes throughout
the episode that people are just acting
out fear in their hate for the androids
it really speaks volumes to first-hand
experience versus secondhand knowledge
and how in Ben
mental towards people that we haven't
really seen up close it can lead to
unfounded hate and distrust gamma Dom
has clearly inspired a lot of hate in
the Romulans and to me it echoes how
things can become ingrained in societies
that lead to people hanging at the
groups of people the crew of La Sirena
techn Eric to the compound is a prisoner
Agnes breaks Picard out and soon
recovers the memory from the murdered
droid and discovers that Sutra was
behind it with the Romulan fleet
approaching Picard decides that he
cannot abandon the children of soon and
he wishes to give them an example of how
human life really is
soon confronts Sutra and deactivates her
whilst the crew disable the beacon
seven of nine and IRISA go head-to-head
on the Borg cube and it really ramps up
towards a big battle I also got to hear
the term off meat which I'll be using to
call my mate with a prosthetic on from
now on so thank you for that Nerissa
Nerissa get some really good dialogue
when going against seven and I think
it's one of the best battles in the
series this for saying all that though I
do think that they did rush to this
point I was expecting Sutra to be a much
bigger foe for the finale but she's
pretty much relegated to playing second
or even third fiddle with what's going
on you've got the big space battle the
seven verse and IRISA fight and the one
at the Beacon so it doesn't really feel
like the ideas that were building up
last week get a chance to develop I
wasn't disappointed with any of the
action it just felt like they were so
desperate to get to this that they
dropped a lot of the plot threads that
had built the wards they had the first
opportunity
seven kills Nerissa as the battle
outside the planet rages on agnes talks
about the maneuver that the stargazer
pulled off and this ties back to the
first episode in which the ship made an
appearance as a model the two enactus
strategy on a grander scale to make it
look like they have an entire fleet and
it isn't too long before they're joined
by a real one now watching Riker arrive
back in the uniform is a standout moment
for the entire season though I love the
ending he got with his family I must
admit seeing him return in this way gave
me goosebumps and it feels like one of
the big money shots that the show has
been building towards the Ihram Oryx
syndrome that Picard has been suffering
from starts to go critical and he pleads
with shoji to dismantle the beacon and
Prue
everyone wrong he trusted to make the
right choice and it's a really heartfelt
moment after she turns off the
transponder
the Romulans return and Riker retreats
after giving a respectful goodbye tis
jean-luc Picard collapses and Shoji
beams him back to the planet where he
I'm not crying you're cry now CBS did
greenlight a second season and set up
that there was a duplicate body so I did
know that this wasn't going to be
permanent though it does pull out the
heartstrings they dragged the death and
the grief that follows it out for as
long as possible and hell they even knew
was sort of Forrest Gump ending with a
butterfly and it does feel more
impactful than if they had have just
initially turned around and resurrected
him we learned that in his dying moments
dr. Soong and Coe were able to scan a
complete neural image of his brain and
download his consciousness into a
machine through a quantum simulation the
show constructs a sort of afterlife for
both Picard and data to have an exchange
in Picard never got the chance to tell
data that he loved him but through
data's memories we learn that he knew he
always did it's through this
conversation that data tells becau that
his consciousness still exists as he
downloaded it before his death he states
that though many desire immortality he
wishes to die to learn what it truly
means to be human
this ties back to the book that Rios was
reading earlier in the season which was
the tragic sense of life this book
states that in order for life to have
true meaning it must be finite
it's only with the knowledge of death
that we give anything true value and I
did like how the conversation alluded to
data's wish for death in order to gain
purpose they say their goodbyes and
Picard returns to the land of the living
through the hosts body that soon was
creating last week it has no
augmentations of howís and it's pretty
much the same crappy old body that he
had last time but he no longer has the
brain abnormality couldn't you just put
him in a 21 year old body or something
you guys suck either way it sort of
resets things to the status quo and
Picard appreciates that his days are
still numbered Picard shuts down the
matrix that data's consciousness now
lives in and we watch his he ages and
dies it's a spellbinding exit for the
character and had to say that this
coupled with the other aforementioned
elements in the episode made it the best
and
this fall on the ship everyone pretty
much gets a happy ending
Rafi and seven get their moment that
that they get woke well bro crowd are
gonna go wild over Agnes in Rio show
that the leaks weren't true and so Jim
Picard realized that they found a home
in one another the ban on synthetics is
now lifted and the group head out into
the stars on their way to season two I
have no idea what happened in Eric
though anyway as a whole I've really
enjoyed Picard there have been a couple
of moments here and there that I think
failed but overall I was quite surprised
to see a lot of backlash towards the
series especially when I enjoyed it
quite a lot
I guess no one hates Star Trek more than
Star Trek fans but bar some consistency
problems with the original continuity I
felt like it has been an interesting
progression for the character I saw a
lot of comments as I was doing the recap
which stated that Star Trek had suddenly
become Welk but growing up to me it
always kind of was this was a show that
had the first interracial kiss on
mainstream TV often explored ideas of
immigration and what it meant to be
human and season one sort of felt like a
continuation of that by the
pronunciation of a couple of people's
names changing every 13 seconds and a
couple of other CGI moments it's hard to
really fault a production and for a
first entry in a new chapter it felt
like a great way to start I found the
new characters all interesting and I
love the subversion that they did with
the Borg I know for sure that I'm
nowhere near as close to the property as
some of the people crying out that it
sucks aw but as a casual fan it got me
way more interested in Star Trek than I
ever was before
so yeah in my eyes that's not a bad
thing but due to some big diversions
from the next generation I can't see why
some are disliking the show even if I
don't agree with them overall though I
had a lot of fun with it and I'm really
interested to see where the season goes
in the future the finale was the best of
the run and I had so many amazing
moments that I'm really excited to see
more I do you feel like they explored
some interesting ideas took jean-luc on
a journey that really evolved the
character and also put some pieces in
place that will lead to new adventures
down the line for me picaud season 1 was
a fun ride an overall is a complete
package at score it at a 7
out of 10 obviously I'd loved hear your
thoughts on Picard so comment below and
let me know I just want to give a huge
thank you to everyone who's followed us
alongside the series and it's been great
watching you fill the videos with
comments and what you've taken from the
show we're currently doing breakdowns of
Westworld season 3 so if you're watching
that then make sure you check them out
after this if you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]